irène chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport
nous sommes encore cette semaine au
chili et c'est dans cette région que
s'installèrent les indiens arrogance ou
xvième siècle guerrier et surtout le mad
il avait quitté l'argentine pour venir
exercer leur domination se dépeuple plus
aux siens il leur a posé aux relents
mapuches et ils s'installèrent dans la
forêt la puissance d un état ne peut
venir à bout de l'opiniâtreté des neiges
à
au centre du chili dont il si alan
domaine marque à la limite du grand
empire précolombien après 1880 les
descendants des indiens à rouen ont été
absorbés par les conquérants et refoulé
dans les réserves
ils ont pratiquement perdu leur ancienne
coutume on retrouve dans leurs gestes
journalier le côté primitif tous les
indiens d'amérique du sud
ils sont cultivateurs éleveurs et
artisans chaussée de peau de chèvre
qu'ils en tiennent par un lacet il
cultive la pomme de terre qui est leur
aliment de base
ils élèvent quelque chose l'un meilleure
monture pour circuler dans ce pays
occidentaux
quelques moutons pour leur consommation
courante
bon
il a la bouche quelques bleus qui tirent
les charges lourdes
on
outre la culture et l'élevage les
arrogances sont artisans avant la
conquête espagnole est fabriquée déjà
des ponchos dans la laine de vigogne il
courait avec des arêtes et se servent l
outil en pierre
il se nourrissait de gibier et de
légumes et préférer la chair humaine
l'arcor répugne aide à la vie en commun
il était à situer et rechercher la
solitude on retrouve ici les mêmes
gestes que chez les indiens d'amazonie
confectionnant leurs hamacs qui est
tissée de la même façon
ayant conservé l'art de leurs ancêtres
il fabrique de nombreuses poteries en
terre rouge du pays
la pièce accueillir et glisser avec une
pierre d'agate
à l'heure actuelle ils façonnent de
nombreux personnages pour les crèches de
noël car le que je trouvais là bas à
cette époque dans cette région du chili
mais les arrogances ont conservé une
tradition millénaire
chaque année au mois de février avant la
moisson les saisons sont inversées tous
les indiens d'une même réserve se
réunissent pour célébrer le match retour
aucun étranger ne peut approcher et
encore plus filmer levitte particulier
de ces troubles
il a été extrêmement difficile de
réaliser les séquences qui vont suivre
il a fallu à gilles berlocq un mois pour
obtenir du cacique chef des indiens
l'autorisation de filmer une des plus
importantes messe de cette puce
chaque famille arrive le jour fixé avec
tout son matériel ménager
c'est un véritable déménagement
la réunion a lieu dans un grand champ
elle va durer quatre jours et quatre
nuits
le mach y tenait une cérémonie organisée
par les indiens mapuche de la tribu
arrogance des prières seront dites pour
chaque membre de chaque famille à tour
de rôle il s'agit d'un blu ray les
esprits pour qu'ils apportent le beau
temps pour les moissons futur chaque
foyer veaux présentés par un gang ou
planté en terre sur une ligne droit de
voir les animaux qui seront sacrifiés
derrière agenouillé et représentants de
chaque famille il prit en versant des
offrandes aux pieds des bambous ses
offrandes sont faites de bois son usage
courant
la ccia fabriqués avec le maïs fermenté
ainsi que le produits alimentaires
farine sel au potage
par instant à chaque extrémité de cette
sorte d'autel un indigent s'époumone en
soufflant dans un instrument appelé trop
tout cas instruments et en bande dans
l'embouchure ressemble à sa lune
de temps à autre on verse de l'eau dans
la trousse rucka pour faciliter les
missions des sons
vous
des offrandes sont versées sur les
animaux à sacrifier nous plonge aux
vaches et toute la cérémonie a un
caractère très solennelle chaque phase
dure environ 10 minutes pour réaliser ce
épouse de lui on avait désigné c'est un
emplacement qu'il ne pouvait pas
dépasser mais jb allik a eu la curiosité
tenace et elle la mena bien souvent en
dehors de ces limites
il fut à chaque fois rappelé à l'ordre
et le deuxième choix revenus il jugeait
plus prudent de ne pas réapparaître car
il craignait une lui arrive à l'accident
après les offrandes viennent les dents
elles sont accompagnées des tambours les
hommes puis les femmes tournent en rond
je suis ravi que toujours identique
pendant ce temps plusieurs cavaliers
montés sur des chevaux galopent formant
un cercle diabolique autour des
officiants pour éloigner les démons se
griller ses dents se font sans
interruption 24 heures sur 24 pendant
quatre jours même si pl c'est une
véritable épreuve d'endurance
d'ailleurs cette façade formant totem
une onde cabanes faites de branches sert
de refuge aux enfants et on y préfère de
menu repas une boisson spéciale appelée
modaï elle ferait avec du blé cuit et
fermenter puisse éclater par écrasement
avec l'équipe c'est chaque jour à midi
conduit les sacrifices des animaux
convergent sur leurs boissons et
victuailles toujours un signe défendent
c'est ensuite une véritable boucherie au
monde s'affaire à préparer un bon repas
mais attention interdiction absolue de
cassé un os qui fait découper
conjointure sous peine de sacrilège
l'avion de présenter face aux bambous
pendant quelques heures ce qui lui
permet d'entrevoir bon poussière le tout
est mieux accueilli et sera consommé
pendant la nuit
entre les danses et les cuillères
irène joliot vous a proposé voyage un
passeport cette émission a été réalisée
avec un film de gilles vers le montage
rené garrigues clickjacking loire sont
maurice teboul gérard benquet nommé hier
justin se leurrent demi paladyne
réalisation se lancent des terres
à